final jigsaw pieces of the Stargate
drama might be falling into place but
how is that related to news about DC
Studios welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi
TV and movie channel
[Music]
first of all the news that Peter Safran
and James Gunn have been hired as the
co-executive producer and executive
producer of the newly formed DC Studios
is I think fantastic news I think it's
actually a really clever idea that David
zaslap has gone in this direction that
he has picked in Peter saffron a manager
and somebody that is very good at
operating at an executive level but
brought in James Gunn as a creative side
man now I initially heard the story that
James Gunn had been put in charge of the
um new DC studio and I thought well
that's crazy he's a very creative guy
he's never sort of been at the executive
level now they've been trying to find
their Kevin FYI for a while but given
finding is actually a very good manager
he's not the most creative person all
he's never been a writer or a director
of things like this he is a showrunner
he is a head man he's the captain of the
ship that is not James Gunn but what
they've done here is very clever they've
had the creative person there's somebody
to give them a creative lead and paired
him with a manager to keep everything
flowing in the right direction but I
hear you cry what on Earth has this got
to do with Stargate you know that's
obviously my favorite thing to talk
about so here goes this might actually
lead into one of the final pieces that
MGM have been waiting for don't forget
that if you enjoy the content you can
hit the join button and become a fully
fledged side tracker that really helps
out the channel you can go to
scygashtrack.com there's loads of like
merchandise things on there and a load
of new designs coming very soon also if
you are new to the channel don't forget
to like subscribe and hit the Bell
notification so you miss none of our new
videos as well as the Sidetrack sides
channel for 89 months now I've been
saying to you that Amazon had a couple
of different ideas in mind of what they
would like to do with Stargate the
sleeping giant of sci-fi
plan a was always to produce a movie
first a movie that would kick-start the
new franchise but they had an idea for a
structure of how they wanted the
franchise to move forward and that
started with a film then a series then
potentially a sequel movie and then move
on to a larger Marvel sort of Style
universe
now it has been assumed and assumed by
me that that plan had kind of been
scrapped because they always said they
then had a plan B that plan B was to
start with a series because you can
produce a series much quicker and they
wanted this on their screens reasonably
quickly for example if the sale had
dragged on for much longer they wouldn't
have pushed forward with a film because
we wouldn't have gotten our screen so
let's say 2025 or even later they'd have
gone with a series first because they
could get it on the screen so then say
six months so we assumed that's where
they were going and the rumors we've
been hearing led into that because we've
been hearing about Hawk ostby and Mark
Fergus setting up a sort of series Bible
and planning a structure for the
franchise moving forwards we then hear
lots of rumors about a showrunner being
decided upon and that they would
potentially be able to join MGM sometime
around Christmas
so how does that lead into the news
about DC and blah blah blah if Amazon do
decide they are going to stick with plan
a and go with a movie they would need a
chief executive in charge of movies at
MGM and guess what
they don't have one
very early on after the sale of MGM to
Amazon was finalized Pam Abdi and Mike
DeLuca quit or were pushed
they left MGM and they were the chief
Executives in charge of movies they very
quickly moved over to Warner Brothers
they are actually the chief executive of
Warner Brother movies today they're
going to be working very closely with
James Gunn and Peter saffron as part of
a very collaborative project on DC
Studios and planning the next 10 years
of DC movies
now why did they quit the rumor is very
clearly that Amazon were not 100 honest
with Pam Abdi and Michael DeLuca during
this six months while they were waiting
for the sale to go through
Amazon made them believe they were going
to continue to have a certain element of
autonomy and creative freedom with MGM
pictures but then the second the sale
went through it became very clear that
that was not a hundred percent honest
Amazon made the argument that due to
covert and things their plans had to
change whether you believe that or not
is up to you but Pam Abdi and Michael
DeLuca obviously didn't and they jumped
ship
since then MGM has not had a chief
executive of movies and the chief
Executives at Amazon pictures have been
sort of taking on that role while they
look for a replacement now the
replacement that they want is a lady
called Emma Watts who was previously the
chief executive at Fox pictures before
the Disney sale and she's done a few
other things since
they apparently according to several
sources including variety and a couple
of people I speak to spoke to Emma
Watson a couple of other people a month
or two ago but Amazon were very
impressed with Emma Watson Emma Watson's
vision for MGM over the next 10 years
she is the woman they want but DC also
wanted it for the new DC pictures and
Warner Brothers have spoken to her more
than once over the last few months now
the rumor I heard was the Emma Watts
favored MGM but there's been a few
little issues with the negotiations
which we'll talk about in a second
she didn't want to go to DC and made
that clear a little while ago because
she didn't think she was going to get
the creative freedom on autonomy that
she wanted as the chief executive of the
new DC Studios
David sassler always had this idea of a
collaborative approach that she really
didn't feel that comfortable with
now she's been negotiating with MGM for
garden nearly two months three months
now why hasn't it happened yet I
personally am speculating here a little
bit but I think she's negotiating very
hard again to get that creative freedom
and autonomy that she wants she wants to
run MGM pictures the way she wants to
run it and Amazon pictures don't Amazon
pictures have a very specific idea of
how they want this run and well that's
causing an interesting negotiation
obviously as well there's going to be a
large Financial package and so on and so
on the contracts when you're bringing a
new chief executive of something and
never 100 straightforwards so we're
moving in that direction so once Emma
Watts is in place though that would be
the final piece they need to start
moving forwards with the franchise but I
hear you crying why couldn't we move
forward with the TV series so I've
spoken to somebody that's it's not
related to MGM but he's sort of spoken
to me about why this might be happening
and again this is based on his opinion
but it is opinion based on somebody that
actually works with Warner Brothers now
and has experience in this area
he has said
when you're creating a major franchise
like this you need two or three
different pieces in place you need
somebody that's going to be the
television showrunner you need somebody
that's going to direct and potentially
be the showrunner for the movie and you
need the executives in charge to then
sit around off that team now Michael
Wright is in charge of script of
material at MGM he would oversee and be
in charge of the TV series
hopefully Emma Watts will become the
chief executive MGM and go and have a
look at some of her credits that she's
worked on she's worked on some major
major projects that you will love um
including like the X-Men franchise and
several other things so I mean this has
all been actually I think in charge of
MGM pictures would be amazing but she
would then in theory be in charge of the
movie part of the franchise a showrunner
would 100 though be involved in both
they would have a foot in both camps and
then you have the director of any new
project and the writers all of these
people need to work together to create a
cohesive franchise or you end up getting
a fragmented product a movie that is one
style or goes in One Direction TV that
goes in another show in another
Direction and it will just become a bit
of a mess
a bit like the sea over the last 10
years and we don't want that again it
looks like this is also going to be
decided around maybe Christmas time I'm
hoping now the DC decision has been
announced and is finalized that will
push for us and that hopefully we'll get
a decision on Emma Watts and MGM I
should say as well are actually making
some big hirings at the moment Monica
Mesa was the staff writer from Lost she
worked on the last season of MacGyver
and she's also a ganterfield and Nix
flicks where she was nominated for a
Peabody Award MGM recently signed hope
for a multi-year exclusive deal also the
killing Eve writer Laura Neal has also
been signed up to again a multi-year
exclusive deal with MGM now I'm not
suggesting either of these ladies are
going to have anything to do with
Stargate but they are the first major
exclusive deals MGM have struck since
the Amazon sale it does show that MGM
are finally starting to actually get a
team together and start moving forwards
the next big hiring they need to do is a
chief executive in charge of movies and
then maybe finally we could start
getting some really official news about
Stargate and I know this is frustrating
for a lot of people it's a roller
coaster also you know if you are regular
side tracking you know I speak to lots
of people and I will tell you rumors I
will tell you what I think about those
rumors whether they I believe them or
not and that at times it's been a very
confusing picture because the picture is
constantly changed we had everything
running up to the sale actually being
finalized MGM ready to go forwards with
a TV show with Brad Wright then Amazon
dropping the hammer and making it very
clear that was not going to happen so
the whole story changed we've then had
lots of different rumors coming about
throughout the TV show and at times
because of the sources I have we've not
had the full picture but it does feel
like we're starting to get that full
picture lots of the rumors that we've
been hearing have finally started to
make a little bit more sense things like
the work that Hawk host be and Mark
Fergus are doing it makes sense if we're
in little bit of a holding pattern the
chief Executives of Amazon want there to
be a cohesive project an idea in mind
they want the TV show and movie Bible
they want the foundations of the project
all up and ready to go then the pieces
can be built on top of that
hopefully the showrunner will be in
place very soon that doesn't necessarily
mean though we will get an announcement
straight away
I'm hoping I will find out who that is
and I will be able to announce it at
some point well that doesn't mean we'll
get an official one because then we're
going to have to wait for the other
pieces to be lined up it's a little bit
like a domino alley effect here lots and
lots of dominoes are being placed we
just have to wait for them all to be in
line before MGM are willing to push over
the first and publicly announce the new
series of Stargate so guys get in the
comments and tell me what you think do
you think this does feel like we're
moving towards something big or does it
feel just like more news and I have to
be honest with you at times I've started
to think this maybe isn't going to
happen it just feels like too long is
going on and there's too many different
rumors and too much going on and maybe
it just isn't going to happen maybe it's
just going to get stuck in development
hell and maybe we're not going to get
Stargate ever but I really want to know
what you think and don't forget if you
are new to the channel like subscribe
hit the Bell notification it really
helps us out and if you enjoy the
content and you want to support the
channel consider becoming a fully
fledged site tracker hit the join button
as always guys please stay safe I'll see
you next time
[Music]